كل القوة للناس
اليوم عندما تخطو خارج هذه
الأبواب
يجب أن تدرك أنك تخوض
حربًا ضد 400 عام
من عنصرية القهر
نعم أنت في خط المواجهة
أنت كذلك  عامل التغيير ،
أنت محرك للتغيير
على الطاولة ، لدينا مجموعة متنوعة من الأسلحة التي
نتبعها في الأساس فقط حتى
يفهم الناس أنك تعرف
النافذة الصغيرة لما هو موجود في
العالم الكبير ،
لكننا سنركز أنا وأنت  على
glock ، إنه السلاح الأكثر انتشارًا في كل مكان
تستخدمه معظم أقسام الشرطة ، ولكن
بغض النظر عن المسدس الذي تريد تعلم كيفية
استخدام الباب مفتوحًا ، فسنعلمك
كل ما تريد لإخبار جميع أساتذتي
أنك ستحصل عليه  مدفوع الأجر إذا تعلمت أو
لا ، فلماذا تهتم حقًا إذا
تعلمت حقًا أم لا
لأنك ستحصل على أموال
بغض النظر عما لن أوقف
راتبك ، أبق أصابعك معًا
ستضغط على يدك و
تأكد من بقاء إصبعك  من على
الزناد ، قم
بتدوير المسدس إلى هذا الموضع ، ثم
تأكد من ضبط يدك على
ما يرام بشكل صحيح ، لذا فإن ما تريد القيام به
هو فتح اليد والتعبير عن هذا الجزء
من
الحزام والذي سيحدث هنا تمامًا
مثل ذراعك  قبضة وإبقاء الأمر مستقيماً
الآن تريد أن تمسك البندقية
بقوة المصافحة الجيدة ليس
أكثر من ذلك ، حسنًا ، لذا مجرد مصافحة
[موسيقى] [موسيقى]
اسمي تايلور فروم وأنا
المدير التنفيذي والمؤسس
نعم فيلي وهي مدرسة تعمل
مع الشباب الذين تسربوا من
مدارس فيلادلفيا ويحاولون
إنهاء المدرسة الثانوية
لذلك يأتون إلينا لأنهم يريدون
إنهاء تعليمهم في
سن 16 إلى 21 وهو العمر الذي نحن فيه
العمل مع
الشباب يقررون من يريدون
أن يكونوا ويقررون كيف
يريدون التغيير إذا
كانوا يريدون أن يكونوا
ليسوا مثل والديهم ، وليس مثل
جيرانهم ، وليس مثل بعض الأشخاص
الذين يأتون من قاسية جدًا  المجتمعات
و
thi  s هي فرصة ، هذا هو الوقت الذي
يتخذ فيه الكثير منهم قرارات بشأن
من سيكونون كبالغين
إذا كنت تعيش في فقر وكل من
حولك يعيش في فقر ،
فمن الصعب أن تفهم لماذا يجب عليك
استيقظ في الصباح ، اذهب إلى المدرسة كل
يوم أو
حاول العثور على وظيفة ثم اذهب إلى هذه
الوظيفة كل يوم وافعل أشياء
ليست بالضرورة ممتعة أو ممتعة ،
وهذا لا يتعلق بالطلاب أو
عن أولياء الأمور حتى ولكن هناك الكثير  من
تاريخ الأشخاص المسجونين
، كان
ولا يزال هناك الكثير من تعاطي المخدرات في
فيلادلفيا وأعتقد أنه إذا كنت تعيش في فقر
وبدون أمل ، فمن الصعب جدًا
التخلص من هذا الأمر ، فمن الصعب
جدًا القيام بالأشياء التي تحتاجها  افعل
ذلك ما تفعله بعد التخرج ، من
المحتمل أن أذهب أثناء تخرجي ، من المحتمل
أن أذهب إلى أتلانتا
وأضع بعض الموسيقى ولست بحاجة إلى الاهتمام إذا كنت
سأذهب إلى المنزل وأذهب
مم-همم فقط على الأشياء البسيطة ولكن مع
هذا
مثل إخوانه كلية تعتقد أنه يمكنك القيام به
بصراحة لا أحب
حقًا فقط نوعًا ما من
الناحية المالية فقط حيث أتينا من
نشأتنا في أشياء الشوارع التي
نشأنا عليها ، أدركنا أنه مثل
ما في 12 13.
life
[موسيقى]
بمجرد خروجنا من هذا المبنى
مباشرةً ، يمكن
لأي منفذ إخباري إعلامي أن يبدأ في
التقاط صور
أو مقاطع فيديو لأي شيء نقوم به ،
ولا يمكننا منعهم من فعل
ما يعنيه هذا هو كل شيء  أننا نفعل ذلك ،
فسيقوم الناس بالمراقبة ،
وهذا يعني أنه إذا كان لديك سماعات في
أذنيك
إذا كنت ترمي القمامة على الأرض
إذا كنت تدفع وتدفع بعضكما البعض
وتتحرك حول
كل هذا يمكن أن يتلوى نحن في
عدة مدارس أه  مدرسة نيلسون مانديلا
في بروكلين ،
جنوب برونكس ، مدرسة المجتمع المستأجرة
الثانوية في برونكس ، هذا هو تحالفنا الشبابي
الذي كنا هناك كل يوم على
مدار الأسابيع الثلاثة الماضية
لتعليم هؤلاء الأطفال حول العنصرية
وتعليم هؤلاء الأطفال عن
وحشية الشرطة  تعليم هؤلاء الأطفال
حول الافتخار بمن
يعلمون هؤلاء الأطفال أن لديهم
القوة ، كل السلطات والأشخاص
الذين لديهم القوة
لإحداث التغيير ،
هذا ما علمناه أن العالم
سينظر إليك ليرى ما
عليك  قل
عن وحشية الشرطة ، هل أنت مستعد
، هل أنت مستعد ، هل أنت
مستعد لإخبارهم بماذا تعني
حياة السود أهمية الحياة السوداء
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
ما الأمر ،
يا صديقي ، سهل ،
هذا أبي هو يعرف الحي
الذي تعيش فيه  هذا الحي نفسه لمدة
52 عامًا ،
كيف تعيش في نفس الحي
لمدة 52 عامًا ،
لقد شهدنا أعمال شغب كبيرة هنا في عام 63
وقد مزقنا المدينة
حقًا ، لذلك نحن حقًا لا نعرف أننا لم نعد
حقًا من
أن السود من
حولنا  هنا دائمًا ما
نعاني من حرب عصابات المدرسة الحكيمة ، دائمًا ما نواجه مشاكل
خلال الستينيات ، كان هناك الكثير من الشرب ،
ولم يكن هناك الكثير من
المشاكل المكتوبة بالعقاقير ، ولم تصبنا مشاكل كتابة المخدرات
حتى
حقًا في 7  في السبعينيات من القرن الماضي ، كان
هناك الكثير من المخدرات المختلفة التي أصابتنا سيئة للغاية ،
فقد
ظهرت البطلة حقًا في السبعينيات ،
وكنا نحاول حقًا العودة
مما فعلناه في الستينيات من القرن الماضي في تدمير
المدينة ،
ثم في الثمانينيات كان المال يتدفق
على الأطفال  كانوا
يحصلون على ما يحتاجون إليه في المدارس
وكان الجميع يحصل على
وظائف وكل شيء هنا كان لا يزال
يحاول البقاء على قيد الحياة
، بدأ الأمر مع عصابة دافئة لكننا
أوقفنا اللعبة الأولى وبدأنا في
خوض حروب المخدرات وتم
تطوير حروب المخدرات منهم
كما تعلمون  كانوا يكسبون المال من
الكراك
الذي كانوا يقاتلون من أجله ، تعلمون أن الأشياء
الموجودة في
الزوايا والشيء الرئيسي هو
أنهم بدأوا في إغلاق المدارس
والبدء في إعطاء الأطفال
أنشطة مختلفة مثل إخراجهم
من صالة الألعاب الرياضية
خارج المدرسة التي أخذوها
أنشطة مختلفة للأطفال لممارستها
ليس لديهم
ألعاب كرة القدم والبيسبول وأشياء من
هذا القبيل للذهاب إليها ،
أتيحت لنا الفرصة للتفوق من
خلال الرياضات التي كان لديهم جيم
أفضل لاعب كرة سلة كان هو عليه
لقد كان ينظر
إليه وقد أعجب به
الأشخاص المختلفون في المدرسة
عندما فعلوا ذلك لأنهم
لم يفعلوا الكثير في المدرسة ، ولم
يعدوا يعطونك الفرصة للبيع لإظهار
أنك تعرف مسؤولية
الأطفال  لا أريد أن أذهب فقط لتعلم
الرياضيات في العلوم الاجتماعية وكل ما
يريدون تعلمه
أكثر من ذلك بقليل في المدرسة
ونفعل المزيد
، فلنذهب
[الموسيقى
] حسنًا ،
لذلك سألنا الطلاب في الربيع
عن عددهم
علمت أنك تعلم أن بإمكانهم وضع أيديهم على
مسدس في غضون 24 ساعة
وشعر كل طالب في المدرسة تقريبًا
أنه يمكنهم وضع أيديهم
على مسدس في غضون 24 ساعة
لا يشتري طلابي أسلحة ولكنهم
يعلمون أن عمهم لديه مسدس وهم
يعرفون مكانه
أو يعرفون أنهم يعرفون شخصًا ما
لديه مسدس ويعرفون
مكانه عندما أقول إنهم يستطيعون وضع أيديهم
على مسدس ، لا أقول إنهم يستطيعون شراء
واحدة
[موسيقى] ،
أغلقها وأغلقها  أسفل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مساء الخير أريد أن أعرض
ماجيتيرا  التقى به البعض منكم هذا
الصيف ، لقد قام بورشة عمل
حول موضوع البنادق السوداء هذا الصيف ،
وهو هنا مرة أخرى للتحدث إلينا اليوم ، نعم ،
ما الأمر ،
ما الذي ترسمونه جميعًا على الرغم من
نجاح هذا الأمر حقًا في مساعدتكم
جميعًا
أم توزيع التنسيق
وقوة ساعدك ،
يجب أن تحصل على عقلك
في شيء واحد طوال الوقت الذي
أبحث فيه وأذهب هذا الفن أعني
التفكير فيه ، لكن البنادق ليست
الإجابة على كل شيء
يمكن للفن  لديه مكان أيضًا يصيب هدفًا على بعد
100 ياردة
بصواريخ صغيرة وهدف صغير
هو أن الفنان الفني
قد أتى إلى هنا العام الماضي من
برنامج workbendy الصيفي ،
لقد كان مساعدة كبيرة ، كان لديه
جانبًا رائعًا حول
ما هي البنادق التي أحبها بالطريقة  لقد
كسر ما هي الأسلحة بالنسبة لنا
، لقد أخبرنا أنه كان في اللون الأسود
أه مجموعة حياة سوداء مهمة ،
لقد كان هنا للتحدث إلينا عن البنادق التي
ركض عليها مرة أخرى رجل
أه السيد يوغي من متجر للأسلحة النارية
في الشارع مباشرة  على تخمير جيرارد
حتى كبروا دخل وتحدث
حول
البنادق وشرح لنا ما كان مسدسًا مستخدمًا
وكيفية تفكيك المسدس وما
هي طرق الدعائم لحملها
وأه الحافظة الباردة
ونظف مسدسك الذي أظهر لنا
أنني شعرت أنني كنت
مفيدًا جدًا ولكن بعد ذلك في  في نفس الوقت ، كان علي
أن أخبرهم أنني لم أجد
شيئًا
معنيًا بكل طالب لأن بعض
الطلاب صوروه كفيلم مزاح كانوا
مرحين لكن marge كانت مساعدة كبيرة
لأنه لم يكن يخدم بعيدًا  من هؤلاء الطلاب
، بقي على هدفه ، لقد بقي أنا هنا
لمساعدة الأطفال على التحدث عن الأسلحة التي
كسرها
بشكل أفضل من أي شخص قام بتكسير
البنادق بالنسبة لي ، لقد كنت
منظمة العفو الدولية لم أكن مهتمًا بمسدس
خلال الخمسة الماضية  سنوات ، لذلك
عندما كسر البنادق ، كان لديه بعض
النقاط الجيدة
جدًا ، حسنًا ، فلماذا ترسم
الرؤوس السوداء أمرًا مهمًا أنفك
وتنتظر ، يجب أن يبدو على الأقل
بالنسبة للبنادق السوداء مرة ثانية ،
حقًا هي منظمة تدريب على سلامة الأسلحة النارية
نذهب إليها أساسًا  إلى
مناطق عالية
الجهل تعرف مرحبًا  أشياء من جرائم gh من
هذا القبيل وأخبر الناس فقط عن
كيفية أن
يكونوا أكثر أمانًا ومسؤولية.
هم أو
فقط بشكل عام
لأن والدي وجدي
يعملان في البحرية
، نعم وقد خدموا في الخارج لذلك
أظهروا لنا الأسلحة والأشياء
وشاهدوا النار نوعًا ما ،
إنها مسألة مهمة حقًا في
مجتمعنا يموت الناس
و  أنت تعلم أن هناك الكثير من عمليات إطلاق النار
الجارية والكثير
منها لأن الناس لا
يفكرون في ذلك من خلال الأشخاص الموجودين
في مجتمعاتهم والذين
يفعلون ذلك يحتاجون إلى المجيء والتحدث
معهم ومشاركتهم بشأن حياتهم
وتقديم المشورة لهم  عن
حياتهم المستمرة وتوجيههم ، أعني
أعتقد أن طلابنا جميعًا يحتاجون إلى مرشدين
في المجتمع
أعتقد أنهم المجتمع
مليء بالأشخاص الذين أعني أنني أعتقد
في الواقع ،
أهم الرموز هم الأشخاص العاديون
الذين اكتشفوا للتو
كيفية الحصول على حياة جيدة ويعملون
ولديهم منزل أم تعرفه لأنني أعتقد
أنك تعرف إحدى المشكلات التي تعرفها
ولديها  لقد كنت أعمل مع هذه الفئة من السكان
لمدة 25
عامًا وأعتقد أن إحدى المشكلات هي
أن الأشخاص المشهورين فقط ليسوا
الأشخاص المناسبين لاستخدامهم كعارضات
لأن قلة قليلة من الناس سيصبحون
نجومًا وهذا ما تعلمه.
يعني أنك إذا كنت محظوظًا وكان ذلك أمرًا
رائعًا ، ولكن بالنسبة لبقية
السكان ، فإن
معرفة التوازن هو كيفية
الحصول على عمل
يرضي عنه والذي يؤتي ثماره
ويؤدي ذلك إلى
إبقائك على علم في المنزل كيف  أن يكون لديك
أصدقاء ،
فهذه مهارات مهمة حقًا
يحتاجون إليها لتكون على غرار
[موسيقى]
نعم
نحن نقف هنا اليوم لأن الحياة السوداء
مهمة نحن نقف هنا اليوم لأننا
نريد أن نتأكد من تنشيط الجيل
القادم  قم بتولي هذه المهمة التي
تم
اغتيال أوميغا إيفرز بسبب ما تم
القضاء عليه بسبب
مقتل إيميت حتى بسبب ما
تم تعليقه من أجل ما تم اختناقه من أجل ما تم اختناقه من
أجل
ما تم إسقاط رامالي جراهام
لمعرفة حقيقة ما نحن عليه  إن
العيش هنا في عام 2017
ليس مختلفًا كثيرًا عما كان
يحدث في عام 1817
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالعلاقات بين
المجتمع الأسود والأبيض
عندما يتعلق الأمر بعلاقة
تطبيق القانون في المجتمع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مرحبًا
[  الموسيقى]
عملنا معهم على قوانين متعلقة
بالسياسة يمكنهم دفعها ،
كما نعمل معهم لتنظيم مسيرة
حياة السود بغض النظر عن
حياة السود مهما فعلوا كل شيء بدءًا
من العلاقات مع الصحافة الإعلامية وحتى
التواصل مع جميع
المسؤولين المنتخبين في الداخل  لوجستيات مدينة نيويورك ،
لقد ساعدوا في التخطيط لها خارج
التنظيم ، لقد ساعدوا في الحفاظ على أمان بعضهم البعض
، وخلقوا علامات على وجود الكثير
من
الأشياء الجميلة التي فعلها هؤلاء الأطفال ولكننا
نتناول الشاي  كيف
يقاتلون وعندما تفكر في المهارات التي
يطورون بها اتصالات العلاقات الإعلامية ،
فهذه هي المهارات
التي يمكن أن يأخذوها إلى
الكلية وإلى الشركات الأمريكية
كطفل أسود بريء وأريد أن
أعرف في المرة القادمة ، فهذه هي المهن
التي يريدون  تابعوا ،
نحن نعلمهم القانون ،
سيكون لدى هؤلاء الأطفال شيئًا ما سيكون لهم
دور في جميع الأطفال الآخرين في
مواقفهم الذين يريدون أن يصبحوا محامين
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق
] الآن نحن على وشك الكتابة
التشريع
حسنًا ، سنذهب ونضغط من أجله في
مبنى الكابيتول في ألباني
أسفل قاعة المدينة ، هؤلاء
الأطفال جزء من التاريخ
ومن المهم أن نجعلهم
جزءًا من القتال
ولكن نعطيهم طريقة لتعزيز التغيير
الذي يريدون  انظر ،
ساعدهم في إنشاء حلول ، فهم
المستقبل ،
هؤلاء الأطفال هم مستقبل
المدينة ونحن
نساعدهم للوصول إلى حيث يحتاجون
إلى أن يكونوا
[موسيقى]
أه
هو من تطبخ
مثلك لم تطبخ في دقائق ، أنا
أطبخ نعم لا شيء
أنا  تم طهيه بالأمس لكنني لم أحصل على
قطعتين من شرائح اللحم لأدخل هنا
، كان الأمر كذلك ، لقد حصلت على اللحم البقري أنا مع
المبتدئين
، هذا جيد بشكل أساسي ، نذهب للتسوق
غدًا ، لقد ذهب كل الطعام ، لقد
طلبت ذلك القميص  في اليوم ، كان علي أن
أقول أنه فاتني ، لماذا لا نحصل على واجبات
منزلية ، والسبب هو أننا لا نحصل على أطفال في المنزل ،
ولا يشعرون
برغبة في القيام بالعمل
إذا كان لديك 40 عامًا ، لديك 40 طفلاً في
فصل دراسي ، لقد حصلت على 40 طفلاً  أوراق الأطفال في أوراق
تيسا بالإضافة إلى واجباتهم المنزلية يقولون ،
لن
نتمكن من القيام بذلك ، لذا لن نقوم بذلك ،
لا نحتاج إلى التعليم ، يجب أن تكون
قادرًا على القيام بذلك بالنسبة لنا ، لا نقول أوه نحن
لا  لا أشعر بالرغبة في القيام بذلك ، لم أستطع
إلقاء اللوم
على المعلمين لأنه في الوقت
الذي تم فيه فصل الواجبات المدرسية عن المدرسة ،
كانت المدرسة تعاني من تخفيضات في الميزانية
، فليس كل يوم ترى
فيه طفلاً على ما يرام ، سأذهب إلى
المدرسة سأفعل ما يجب أن أفعله ،
يجب أن أتأكد من خروج عائلتي من
غطاء محرك السيارة ، وأتأكد من أنني أفعل ، سأذهب إلى
المدرسة
لسبب  ليس كثيرًا من المرات التي ترى فيها أن
الكثير من الناس يعتقدون أن المدرسة هي
شيء أحب أن
أستيقظ منه.
نعم ، كان لدينا مدرسون أفارقة ومعلمون للغة العربية
لا يتحدثون الإنجليزية بشكل مثالي ،
لكنك جعلتهم يعلمون فصلًا لمحو الأمية ، ولا
أستطيع أن أفهم ما
يقولونه ، لذا كيف تقوم بتدريس القراءة
ولكن هذا فقط بسبب المدرسة ،
فقط تخفيضات الميزانية التي كانوا عليها  محاولة
ملاءمة الفصل الدراسي في الأوقات
المناسبة والمكان المناسب ، فهمت
أنهم يحاولون فقط جعل الناس
يتعلمون ولكن لا يمكنك محاولة تثقيف
الناس إذا كان الشخص الموجود في
الفصل
لا يعرف المعرفة هم أنفسهم
عندما نتعلم كيف نتعلم أن
كل شخص لديه مكان مختلف ، سأقول فقط
أه المكان بقدر
ما يفعلونه المزاحمون النادي الراقي
دفع الموت
الأحمر حصلت الغرفة الحمراء على بريق في هذا الجانب هنا
لا أريد أن أكون في فيلم هنا
ولكنك لا تعرف
[موسيقى]
لا يمكنك التمثيل  بصفتك ضابط شرطة
دون
سبب محتمل ، حتى لو رأيت
شخصًا يبدو
مريبًا ، فإنه يفعل شيئًا
مريبًا ، لا يمكنك بالضرورة أن
تفعل الكثير حيال ذلك ما لم تره
يفعل شيئًا محددًا ،
لذلك قد ترى شخصًا ما يقف في مكانه
ويكون الجو باردًا حقًا
وهم بمفردهم وتتساءل عما يفعلونه
ولكن لا يمكنك البحث عنهم حقًا أو
أي شيء من هذا القبيل
قد تبحث عنه [موسيقى] الأشياء النموذجية التي قد تبحث
عنها هي الأشخاص الذين
يخرجون في الطقس البارد أو في أماكن غريبة
من المدينة ،
يمكنك مراقبتهم من مسافة بعيدة
إذا لم يتمكنوا من
رؤيتك ،
إنه تحت الصالون هناك ، إنه في
حانة
يقف بالخارج وقد يعرف الناس بالداخل
أنه إذا كنت تريد أي شيء
بالخارج
ورؤية ذلك الرجل والتقاطه  واسترجعها
مرة أخرى
ولكن هناك احتمالات أنه لن
يتعامل في الشارع إذا كان
خارج الحانة إذا كان لديه أي اتصال
بالحانة
لأن أفضل طريقة للتعامل في حالة البار
هي في غرفة الرجال
هذا الرجل هنا  دعونا نعطي h  أنا حسن
المظهر وهو ينظر إلى الوراء ،
فهذا أمر جيد إذا كنت ترتدي الزي العسكري إذا
كنت في طراد ،
فهو يعلم أنك رأيته لذا قد
يقرر عدم
القيام بأي عمل آخر الليلة
، فهو يقف هناك في الظلام ولماذا
و  مرة أخرى ، إنها حلقة متشابهة ثابتة
حول ما إذا كانت بعد خمس
دقائق أو بعد 20 دقيقة ،
ستعود مرة أخرى الآن ما الذي سيفعله
إذا كنت ترتدي الزي العسكري إذا كنت في
طراد وهو يعلم أنك شرطي
ربما يكون خطرًا أقل إذا كان يعلم أنك
شرطي إذا كنت ترتدي الزي العسكري
فهو يعلم أنك رأيته يعرف
أنك رأيته واقفًا
هناك وقد تعود من مكانه
وربما من الأفضل ألا يحمل أي شيء من
الأفضل ألا يكون فيه  في منتصف
التعامل مع أي شيء من
هذا القبيل إذا كنت تعمل متخفيًا ،
فأنت لا تريد حقًا أن يتم رؤيتك ،
فأنت لا تريد إجراء اتصال بالعين
مع الرجل إلا إذا كنت ترغب في
عقد صفقة
معه ، فأنت بالتأكيد لا تريد ذلك.  لا ترغب في
جعله مشبوهًا على الرغم من أنك قد
ترغب في إجراء
اتصال بالعين من حيث المصطلحات
لإعطائه فكرة أنك تريد شيئًا ما
[موسيقى]
متجر البيتزا هذا هنا
والذي يمكن أن يعتمد على التأخير
الذي
يمكن أن يكون فيه متجر البيتزا مكانًا يتجمع فيه الناس
ويذهبون إلى هناك في وقت متأخر من
الليل  مكان مفتوح على مدار 24 ساعة في اليوم
أو في وقت متأخر جدًا حيث
سيذهب الناس بعد الحانات
وقد يرغبون في استمرار
الحفلة قليلاً حتى
يكون ذلك مكانًا جيدًا للبيع